hey guys it's Justine and in this video
we are checking out probably the most
interesting smart home camera that I
have ever encountered this is the genie
s camera from syn labs and it's the
first ever GPT enabled smart home camera
now I say smart home camera but this
little device does so much more than
just keep an eye on things the GES has
this unique and compact design it shoots
vertical video it has a built-in LED
spotlight motion detection and tracking
two-way audio Advanced smart home
Integrations and amazing built-in AI
capability with a feature called vay
generative AI is bringing in an all new
era of advancements and all kinds of
tech so it's really exciting to be able
to get my hands on the first ever GPT
enabled camera a huge thank you to syn
labs for partnering with me on this
video and sending me this to check out
let's get into
it here it is capture sink
share oh my gosh it's so cute look at it
it's like a little it's like a Little
Robot oh my gosh it's so
cool see what else we have in the
Box got a nice USBC cable and it's super
flat power
brick hi I'm Genie I'm so here for it
now the main reason that I was so
interested in this is because of the AI
capabilities now they're launching this
feature called vus which basically turns
the camera into a super smart camera it
can recognize more than 2,000 types of
objects and it will convert what the
camera sees into text descriptions so
you can actually search through your
recordings by keyword and this also
allows you to customize the
notifications that you receive so you
can be alerted about specific areas or
objects or people or pets inside of your
home now first of all can we talk about
how freaking cute this thing is like
look at it it's like a little camera
friend and I feel like we should
probably give it a name so if you guys
have a suggestion for our genius name
leave it in the comments below and the
top comment wins I also love how
affordable this is it comes in two
storage options a 32 gig for $34.99 and
a 64 gig version for only $39.99 and the
view sa subscription will only be 9
cents for the beta version at launch and
it's live right now for anyone to
try oh did you see that there's a little
light okay time to set up oh my gosh
what are you
doing what are you doing
doing um I'm sorry
hello all right let's add a new
[Music]
device ready to connect okay you that
was pretty fast Bluetooth pairing
succeeded okay it's connecting set up
completely oh my goodness hello can yeah
you guys can see that it's do it's just
this is so freaking cool so we're here
in the studio now I can control this
with the app look like I just drag my
finger what the heck this is so freaking
cool like how cool is that like this
interface is awesome I'm going to turn
it around to see
me you're so close to my face get out of
here oh it can't okay so I turned you
all the way around so basically goes
through 360 but you have to turn it all
the way back around oh look at it I'm
recording come back over
here hi hello oh this is so cool okay
let me move you back hi just testing out
the genie s what does this look like
what does it sound like oh boy I can't
wait to set this up somewhere in my home
and start actually using it I'm going to
try the object recognition so let's
click right here and it is scanning
scanning
scanning whoa here's all of the tags it
tagged everything hair head face
forehead hair eyebrow nose mouth neck
shirt necklace arm wall how cool okay
here's a little Spotlight so I can turn
the spotlight on I can make it brighter
too holy moly that is so bright look at
this you could adjust just like
so so we can change the aspect ratio
okay so this is taking
pictures uh
call
hello okay
oops it calls the
camera so up here you can change the
video quality so we can have 2K HD we're
going to keep it in 2K because that's
how we roll so here's all my media the
photos that I have taken wonderful we'd
love to see it oh my gosh I can't wait
to actually try this out okay so this is
so cool now we have the basic setup done
and I think it's now time to find a home
for this little guy in my house and
really put it to the test you guys okay
so I had to come back I had to come back
because I just got a notification from
Genie and because this like alerts will
pop up like little notifications telling
you what that it thinks it sees it says
a man is taking a picture of himself in
front of a camera possibly using a
tripod what I I mean other than the fact
that I'm not a man I don't even know
what to I'm just like I was getting
ready to take a thumbnail photo and it
just said what I was doing I'm I'm shook
okay I got to take my thumbnail I know
so I have it all set up and this thing
is so shocking like I set it up and I
was just going about my business setting
up to film and I get this notification
where it says a woman is standing in a
kitchen holding a camera taking a
picture of a countertop but little does
this know I was actually taking a
picture of it so technically yes I was
taking a picture of a countertop like
I'm personally being ATT attacked now
and I absolutely love it so now let me
take you through some of these features
and show you really how this app work
works I've only been using this for
about a half an hour and I am so
impressed already I can't wait to
actually have this in my home up and
running and be able to really see the
capabilities of it over time so here we
are inside of the app like I showed you
earlier you have the ability to scroll
around you can go left and right up and
down so obviously like I'm filming in
here so we can see the camera I like
that I do have this in my kitchen so I'm
able to get kind of like a full view of
the entire living room area and I'll be
able to see if anyone goes Upstairs
Downstairs or I can even go over here if
I want to see what's going on at the
kitchen sink so when we go into the
settings you we have tracking Spotlight
turn off and on and we can adjust the
framing so we can go three four or full
screen we also have co- watch which is
pretty awesome so when I go into this
this will take us into this menu where
we'll be able to send a link to someone
so like if I want to send this to my
sister like she could actually watch me
film right now and I also like that it
allows you to add a password so now we
also have in here some past events this
is where I got the notification saying
that the woman was taking a picture of
of a countertop and like it could not be
more accurate so when we go in here to
do the photo recognition this is where
it uses Ai and it determines what we're
actually seeing in this image and this
is so wild because this will tag
everything so you can see the amount of
times that you've seen a woman a stand a
face a wall a camera and you can go
through and sort all of these things out
but this is an example of what the
entire image looks like with these AI
overlays and it's pretty fast fting
because it really does get everything I
mean it's like face hair door handle
stand pool chair chair low pillow table
like just wow so I can download this and
I can share it and what's great is this
was an autogenerated event it gave me
that notification that used AI to
determine what was in the scene and when
I click on it I can go and save it share
it with my friends or post it online or
basically just do whatever I want this
has a calendar r view so I can go in and
I've only been using it for a day so far
I don't have any previous history but
you'll be able to go back to specific
days and what is great is this does do
local storage so we're not sending this
stuff to the cloud it is all happening
locally on device I can go up here and
do a little search oh look at that look
at all okay look at this one a person
using a camera to take a picture of a
kitchen possibly for a video or still
image like these are
so accurate now when I go into playback
this gives you a little timeline history
a woman sitting at a table smiling and
eating food a I actually wasn't eating I
was drinking but you're on the right
track we can also turn on the little
Spotlight so if it is dark in your room
wherever you have this camera you can
turn this on to give you a little bit
better of a lighting situation this also
has voice commands so you're able to
start and stop video which is pretty
cool because you don't have to actually
go into the app you can just use your
voice and be able to talk to it speaking
of talking it does have two-way audio so
let me go do a little demo of that I'm
going to go outside and then I'm going
to call it and talk to it so let me pan
around here to get myself going outside
I also love that this records vertical
video which is pretty cool like thank
you for taking into consideration that
vertical is a thing of the future or the
now I'm not sure okay here we go I'm
going out okay I'm going to make my call
I'm going to go further away hello hello
can you hear me little camera can you
hear me inside W this is so cool I can
look up I can look
down
go turn all the way around see the
camera and my
drink okay great I'm going to hang up
now so I really love this viewa feature
and it's so easy to go back and find any
moment that you want on video it'll
automatically arrange similar videos in
chronological order with text based
descriptions so you can get this really
cool visual timeline of everything so if
I want to see more of a woman standing
outside looking at her cell phone and
appears to be texting or checking her
phone oh my God go it pulls actually I
didn't expect this to pull up the other
instances of me on the phone wow there's
so many possibilities for this I
freaking love it now obviously I'm just
testing this out and kind of figuring
out how I want to have my settings but
what is really cool is it actually has
intelligent alerts so in kind of like a
real world scenario I don't really want
to be getting all of these notifications
about everything that is happening so
with these intelligent alerts I can turn
off these notifications something that I
really want to try out is the tracking
so let's turn on tracking and um see if
attracts
me oh look at
that I mean this is so wild like look at
it following me everywhere I
go that's actually pretty fast too
that's impressive so far I'm so
impressed with this like this is such a
unique way to be able to use Ai and
integrate it into our daily lives and
what makes me so excited about this is
because we have the abil ability to do
software updates and firmware Updates
this thing is only going to get better
so I'm seriously so impressed with this
little camera and I think that people
would be quick to label this as just
another security camera but honestly I
think that this goes way beyond that the
AI features really make this something
unique that I've never seen before in a
smart home camera and even as a content
creator I can see this being amazing for
capturing video as well and the fact
that it records 9 by6 vertical video is
so perfect for creating content for
social media but really this camera is
perfect for all kinds of things
capturing moments with family keeping an
eye on your kids or pets even live
streaming I feel like there are so many
ways that you could really get creative
with the Gen I mean you guys know that I
review a lot of cameras and a lot of
tech and this just seems like this is in
a whole different category of its own in
the world of smart home cameras it
really is groundbreaking and I think
this will pave the way for more awesome
Tech like this in the future but I'm
curious about what you guys think leave
me some comments below I would love to
hear from you if you guys are interested
in getting more information about the GS
or to buy one for yourself there is a
link in the description thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this video this was so much fun
to check out don't forget to like
comment and subscribe and be sure to hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos and of course I have a bunch more
here on the end screen if you want to
check out other videos and what I've
been up to lately see you guys in the
next one bye